at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey you guys what's going on
that that intro I know every single time
we watch it we're like God damn that's
interesting
we're just constantly patting ourselves
I should have put my titties yeah I just
haven't pressed well I according to you
A million hits according to you yeah you
have to have spinning and everything
yeah spinning titties
you know I'm gonna call it some dirty
[__] you know I'm gonna [__] come on
spinning titties
things orbiting around them
a gravitational pull yeah like a
gravitational pull yeah I mean is this
are we gonna be are we gonna be able to
like do a serious show or not I mean
yeah it can't be [__] around well I
mean you know it doesn't have a serial
killer Theory well he's not no he's not
a serial killer that's right multiple
personality well
um I thought he killed some of them
that allegedly okay
he's a rapist okay is what he is uh but
allegedly he might have killed a couple
people not the women that he raped
but a couple of other people allegedly
all right I have to say allegedly he's
dead but I mean
you know what I mean I just remembered
this case vaguely I hadn't studied it
Jane he did all the study on it yeah I
watched there's um if you haven't seen
it there's a four-part miniseries on
Netflix which is called Monsters Inside
the toy what is it called the 24 faces I
think it's called the 24 faces of Billy
Milligan and there's a couple of other
kind of in-depth like YouTube videos
about it like Simon Whistler did one on
casual criminalist it was like an hour
long and that was really good I listened
to that in the car and uh you know there
was a couple of other ones on there not
a huge amount and Dr Grande
who is a psychiatrist who posts stuff
like pretty much every day I think and
he's always like talking about whatever
cases are in the news and he did one and
he's great because he's like so he seems
like so straight laced and he always has
he has this very very deadpan voice so
it's like he'll he'll be talking about
the case and then like he'll make a joke
but for a second you don't realize it's
a joke because it's the same like
monitor that he said the rest of the
[__] in and it's like for some reason
that just tickles the hell out of me
because it's like that is humor is just
like so [__] dead he never cracks a
smile he never anything like that and
it's just like so funny
um let's see
so I spin those titties yeah does Tom
have a lactation fetish
um yeah I don't know if you call it a
fetish an appreciation for it but yeah
he does have a thing yeah a thing for
that yeah there's just something about
it's sexy as [__] just the life-giving
essence of the book
trying to that's right we can do that
nurturing you and trying to give you the
nutrients
that you need to develop into it into a
big boy
if you were breast fed then all people
have that concept I think and I've come
across some of the videos of that we're
just focusing on that yeah that's kind
of hot man that's kind of hot it is kind
of yeah in a weird way I just remember
that Japanese movie where the dude was
just massaging that girl yeah that she
was spraying it that was kind of that
was pretty [__] hot no sex happened
I just kind of I just thought it was it
was like man she can shoot far
yeah on a black background yeah like
damn
spray it out like a damn shower
[Music]
[Laughter]
that looks like it takes a lot of
practice or I don't know that might be
that might be a natural Talent I'm not
really sure yeah Trey said it was
spinning titties I thought you said
spitting titties no I said spinning yeah
he's done spinning with things orbiting
around him because well that's the
reason he brought up lactation was
because he thought he said spitting
on spitting titties
it's funny that he mentioned that [__]
though
my uh my uh
gay muscle porn friend says man if you
take if you take Natural on along with
[__] tread you might lactate and I
was like what I said no just said it
casually like yeah yeah I've lactated
before on that and I was just like with
all that [__] together and I was just
like well I won't be taking all that
together no more training he's like okay
just warning you if you take those two
together along a test you could lactate
that's because I do it you know and I
was like
I almost was tempted to ask you making
gay porn with that too
I mean you might as well might as well
well it's happening you take a break and
dominating those twinks and [__] because
he does he just
dominates twinks and [__] but you know
well you know three does Ben said was
this episode planned or is it because
you were talking about this multiple
personality rapist scam thing the other
day well we were talking about the other
day because
um somebody recommended this topic quite
a while ago and even before I knew that
there was a Netflix show about it so I
wrote it down it was on the list I put
it in the poll a couple times but it
never won and then I put it in the poll
this past time and it won so I don't
know if that had anything to do so like
I said I actually did go and watch the
Netflix thing about it
Zach said uh Jenny I need an opinion I'm
doing a fan edit of a movie and I want
to rewrite a credit in the titles but
the titles were done in a custom font
that's not available I don't know what
to do
um I don't really know what to tell you
man other than finding something like so
similar that no one will notice or I
mean I've been in that
boat and uh a lot of times I'm just like
well [__] it I'm just going to start
over like with my own font
but I guess you can't really do that but
either that or you could just like make
it like really really really different
so you weren't trying to because I kind
of feel like it's it's more noticeable
if you try to make it look like the
other one but it doesn't quite look like
it you know what I mean
Zach said reminds me of a story someone
told about having a baby and their dog
started lactating yeah that's just so
interesting yeah that doesn't that's not
that strange yeah a female dog knows
when a baby's born might need milk I
mean you never know she might think
that's my baby
my baby yeah yeah
Celtic Angel 73 is here hello I hope
everyone is doing yell well I can't even
[__] talk this is gonna be great
isn't it it's gonna be a long show no
it's not but I mean you know what I mean
just I'm just having trouble talking
already and I'm not even drunk I've had
like a sip Jenny been working all day we
got up early this morning yeah he got up
the same time as me yes I was molesting
you yeah I know at five o'clock in the
morning yeah I couldn't help
and I was like I kind of got to get up
because yeah one I gotta get ready I
gotta get ready to go to work and two I
had some freelance [__] I had to do like
before I went to work so that's why I
had to get it back she has people [__]
[__] happens it does uh but yeah before
we get too much into the topic I think I
neglected to mention but we did get a
PayPal donation oh damn it that was
someone named jemisin I think hopefully
I'm pronouncing that right if I'm not I
really apologize uh but thank you very
much for your generous PayPal donations
uh or patreon or whatever the hell you
want also got David June's shirts done
yeah yeah I got it now if David June is
in the comments I don't see him I'm
pretty sure I have his address somewhere
but it would be good if he would send it
to me again just in case yeah because
who knows where I put that got two of
them just like that yeah 2XL
there you go
and I tried to put the I tried to put
the emblem up higher that way it's not
the center
yeah it looks better on you when it's
higher
Zach said now I'm wondering could a baby
survive off the milk from something
besides a human yes probably yeah I
don't think it's that different I mean
it's a mammal isn't it yep mammals are
dive off of cow milk you might need some
other nutrients but I don't think dog
would be a big difference yeah I don't
really think it would kill you or
nothing like that I mean it might not be
ideal but it probably but it would
probably work in a pinch yeah I would
imagine like I said mammals are not
really that different even Roman even
Roman Legends said Romulus and Remus
were uh breast fed by a she-wolf or was
it a she dog I think it was a sheep I
think it was a wolf yeah yeah I mean
founders of Rome it didn't happen but
yeah they must have known that that
sometimes having feral children is what
they're talking about
and that's actually happened in the
modern era yeah yeah
I think we did a show about feral
children didn't we yeah a long time ago
and I will say too I was thinking about
this earlier because this particular
case the Billy Milligan one there is a
link to the Sybil case of multiple
personalities
um you know which I'll get into in a
little bit and we did do a show about
Sybil uh a long time ago I think it was
one of the first I think it's probably
like in the first year that we started
doing the show we just show about Sybil
and I think on that show I can't
remember it and I didn't have time to
like re-listen to it
I'm pretty sure that we
because we talked about what they used
to call multiple personality disorder
now they call it dissociative identity
disorder and it's still to this day a
very very controversial disorder with a
lot of psychiatrists and therapists and
stuff like that thinking that it doesn't
really exist and I don't know I I don't
know like I said I'm not a psychiatrist
I'm not trained in that or anything like
that but it does seem to me that some of
the symptoms that it uh presents as
would be really really hard to
scientifically
prove you know what I'm saying and I
think when they have tried to like
scientifically prove it it's you know it
doesn't um they can't really distinguish
like between someone that quote unquote
really has it or someone who's just
faking like for the sense of a sense of
an experiment so we'll get into that a
lot for this case because Billy Milligan
was a case where
um he really did kind of if you don't
know he's pretty much the only person in
American legal jurisprudence or whatever
that actually did successfully uh argue
or rather his defending attorneys did
that because he had dissociative
identity disorder uh that he was not
legally culpable for the crimes he had
committed now he did he wasn't just like
let loose in the street not immediately
anyway but um he was put in a series of
mental institutions like rather than
being sent to prison but that's always
been like a controversial
uh diagnosis because no one is entirely
sure I don't think even to this day and
they kind of left it like on the Netflix
documentary this you know no one really
knows whether he actually did have this
disorder and he was like legitimately
didn't know that this other personality
had committed these crimes or whether he
was just a really really good con man
um I will say that if he was a con man
he wasn't exceptionally good one
um but
as far as IQ tests and stuff like that
he did seem to be exceptionally
intelligent not like genius level or
anything but I mean like very very
highly intelligent like I think they
said his IQ was 129 or something like
that which is you know way above average
so
I don't know I I don't know how I feel
about it I'm kind of on the I'm kind of
on the side of he probably was faking it
but if he was faking it he was like real
committed to faking it because it went
on for a long time and he did it even
when he wasn't
um because that's the thing he for sure
had mental health issues and I don't
think anyone is arguing that I think
what the controversy is is whether it
was actually multiple personality
disorder dissociative or whether it was
something else he clearly had some
mental health issues the issue is like
what were they and was he aware that he
was committing these crimes like you
know was he not legally culpable for it
but that's kind of like what the um
documentary is about so the documentary
which is four apart so it's like about
four hours long and I watched it like
over the last two or three nights it's
um I kind of feel it's really good like
parts of it are really interesting
I kind of felt like it was a little
dry though slightly
in Parts but overall it was like pretty
good and pretty interesting but there
are like some other like YouTube videos
and stuff like that there about it that
are uh also kind of interesting
uh let's see maximum security Insanity
prison have you ever done a show on
Francis e deck that's why I don't think
so
uh Ben said it really depends if he
developed his condition before or after
his arrest well yeah and I want to get
into that too because there is some
controversy about it there's been a book
about him
um that was actually written by Daniel
Keys who also wrote Flowers for Algernon
which is like a really really famous
book we all I read it in school
and I've read it subsequently since then
and it's called the minds of Billy
Milligan but and like I said there's a
link to Sybil as well because Sybil the
book by uh Cornelia Wilbur Dr Cornell
Wilbur
that came out I think the book came out
in 1973 and then remember they had that
TV movie with Sally Field yeah and that
came out in 1976. a long time ago I was
a kid when they came out yeah yeah and
it so happened that the whole Billy
Milligan thing
um his arrest was in 1977.
and you know multiple personality
disorder was kind of very much in the it
was very trendy yeah at the time because
even before Sybil came out I think you'd
have that maybe like the three faces of
Eve which was kind of about that as well
which is fictional but you know what I
mean so it was very much like in the
public Consciousness at the time so it
could have been that he's like oh this
is something that I could use to get out
of responsibility like I said I'm not
saying he wasn't mentally ill I'm not
saying that he wasn't horribly abused as
a child it seems that he probably was
but
I don't I don't know if I really buy
that he didn't realize one of his other
personalities was running around doing
this [__] you know what I'm saying I
read civil like I did too like 82 or 83.
uh I think it was in Military Academy
and um I thought it was a fascinating
story but the more I thought about it I
wasn't quite sure I bought it
I was like I don't think that actually
happened a lot of therapists don't yeah
I don't think it is in the um the
diagnostic and statistical manner the
DSM it is in there but a lot of um
psychiatrists and stuff like that don't
think it should be in there so it's even
nowadays it's still very controversial
uh kalon asked can MPP MPD show up on a
brain scan I don't believe that it can
and I think that's one of the reasons
why it's so controversial is that
you don't one it would be super easy to
fake it yeah that's one thing and you
can't like when they've done experiments
where they you know would send different
patients to therapists that had actually
been diagnosed with it
um versus like just plants that were
pretending
um a lot of the therapists couldn't tell
the difference
um because there is no there does not
seem to be any significant physiological
changes between like when one person is
like going from one personality to
another
um there's really no way of proving that
somebody has it and some of the I feel
like some of the um symptoms for it are
kind of more associated with other
you know pathologies maybe it was like
narcissistic personality disorder
schizophrenia something like that and I
kind of feel like that Billy Milligan
when he was growing up like I said he
definitely had mental health issues from
a childhood like even before he
manifested any personalities or anything
like that
um he was diagnosed with various like
you know schizo schizophrenic type stuff
and things like that so he did have
problems with the civil case though
reason why I said I didn't buy it is I
remember her telling stories about her
childhood and her mom and some of that
[__] was way outlandish I don't think
that could have happened to some of the
stuff that she talked about in there
well as far as I know
um the woman or Sybil obviously was not
her real name her real name is Shirley
Mason but she apparently later on wrote
a letter to the doctor that wrote the
book about her Cornelio Wilbur and said
I made it all up yeah that's right I
thought so yeah see because I remember
we did a show about it now Cornelia
Wilbur for whatever reason either
because she legitimately thought oh
she's just saying that to get out of her
treatment or whatever or because she's
like hey I've been writing a book about
this and I'm Gonna Be A Millionaire
um she didn't tell anybody that was that
was before that was before like [__]
Geraldo and [__] Jerry Springer and
[__] before daytime talk shows were had
gotten super [__] raunchy so if you
came up with a book like this man it'd
be a Smash Hit because it was new to the
market I think it sold six million
copies I think because it was wild I
remember reading it yeah it was a crazy
story but I also remembered that there
was a lot of [__] that I was just like I
was astounded but she was saying about
what her mom used to do mom used to walk
around and like take a dump and the
neighbors front yard in the middle of
the oh yeah that's right [__] and then
and and would fight with other people
and I was just I mean people do do that
so it's not I just remember that just
the sum total of everything that was
happening and I was like I don't think
this happened this this chick's tripping
I just I just thought it was a book
written by Crazy Girl
well it just sounded too outlandish kind
of like because what it really what it
was it was like on par some of it I
remember looked like the seed that
planted the satanic panic and the ritual
satanic uh abuse
it was more um the satanic Panic thing
mostly came from a book called Michelle
remembers okay which was a similar kind
of thing but that was where that was
where they got into the whole like
recovered memory syndrome where it's
like people were going to therapists
saying you know I could and I the same
thing happened with Sybil AKA Shirley
Mason Shirley Mason she actually went to
Cornelia Wilbur with other problem she's
like oh I'm you know having memory
problems or you know blackouts insomnia
things like that she didn't say anything
about having multiple personalities but
the more that she was in therapy the
more personalities came out and it has
been suggested I don't know if this is
true or not but that Cornelia Wilbur Who
was very interested in dissociative
identity disorder AKA multiple
personality disorder thought that maybe
that's what her deal was and like gave
her some books to read about it and
stuff like that which maybe planted the
idea in her head yeah so um I think I
think so it's kind yeah it's kind of
like a similar thing to recovering
memory syndrome where a lot of people
you know like for example Michelle
remembers which was one of the things
that kicked off The Satanic Panic which
we've done a couple shows about that
where somebody will go to a therapist
and say you know oh hey I'm having
trouble sleeping or I'm having
nightmares or I'm having like some other
like mental health issues that they want
help with and if you have a therapist
that is really dead set or really
interested in this one particular area
of study and they're not entirely
ethical perhaps
um and maybe they don't even know that
they're doing it like consciously I'm
not sure maybe
um you know maybe they're so interested
in this one thing that it's like
everything looks like that to them so
it's like they just kind of wittingly or
unwittingly like steer their patients
down this particular path and a lot of
times depending on what the patient's
personality is like sometimes they're
like well they want to do good they want
to like please the therapist so they're
gonna start acting the way the therapist
wants them to act and answering the way
they want them to answer I remember my
theory was was is that because I
remember that other one that Michelle
remembers that that was called I
remember that book too I don't think I
don't think I read it yeah I didn't read
that one I read simple but yeah I
remember that they were like selling it
on the daytime talk shows yeah after
having her on there
and I remember in those days thinking
that
this Michelle remembers State and that
was a bit that was a big [__] hit all
right to me I was like that sounds like
a reboot of civil yeah and I think
that's what it was yeah it seemed like
very similar yeah and I'm not and I
don't really want to Discount because I
know that like some people that have
mental health issues I know dissociation
is a thing
um you know and I know some of the
things that are associated with multiple
personality disorder you know are real
symptoms of things I just question
whether it's as
egregious as it's usually shown in this
case and like in Sybil where where you
know you have a dozen people living in
your head you don't know about each
other and stuff like that I'm not saying
it couldn't happen I'm just saying that
it's prob if if it does exist it's
probably much rarer than I mean it's
probably like super super rare
and I kind of feel like
um you know after three phases of Eve
after Sybil after the Billy Milligan
case it seemed like the diagnosis of
that like went way way up
even though a lot of therapists are
still to this day like not convinced
that it even exists like as a separate
diagnosis you know what I mean just not
so much that the individual aspects of
it don't exist obviously but that
just the way that it's described in the
manual they don't think that it's that
out there you know what I mean
and like I said I'm not saying that
dissociation and like you know
particular types of Amnesia particularly
with children that have gone through
like horrible trauma and abuse that's
usually the kind of people that manifest
with this type of stuff and I'm not
saying that that doesn't have horrible
damaging effects I just don't know if
it's this particular effect that's all
like I said I don't know
um okay so let's kind of start with
I didn't I didn't necessarily just want
to start like with his um I might like
jump back and forth but what I'm going
to do is I'm going to start with his
crimes and how he first came to the
attention of the World At Large you know
what I mean
so this happened back in 1977.
now a lot of the early stuff uh happened
in Ohio now he he was originally from
Florida he's from Miami but um we'll get
into that but he lived in Ohio with his
mom and his siblings and stuff
so what ends up happening in October of
1977. and these rapes because he was
called the campus rapist
for reasons which will soon become
obvious
the the series of rapes that he did it
was over a very short period was I
believe it was like less than two weeks
because he got caught like almost
immediately and we'll figure out why
that is in a minute
so October 14th 1977.
this happened on the um Ohio State
University campus
and apparently uh Billy Milligan he
pointed a gun at an optometry student
there
and essentially like kidnapped her took
her from a parking lot in the middle of
the day uh and took her to a wooded area
and raped her
uh afterward he made her write a check
and cash it for him he was also he would
Rob his victims as well he would like
take all their credit cards and it was
was he one of these Sweet Talkers
or was he mean to him
one of the and this is this is so
[__] weird yeah so according to like
a lot of the sources that I read they
said one of the women I don't know if it
was this first one because he raped
three women
during this time period
one of the women actually told the
police later like after Billy Milligan
was caught
that um he was like really nice yeah to
her and that had circumstances been
different I.E if he hadn't been pointing
a gun in her face and raping her then
maybe she might have considered dating
him yeah and I was like what a strange
thing to say well there are women that
have fantasies about that well I know
that but you can you can find erotica
been written by women about this yet
yeah I know uh you got dudes that also
kind of
fall into that same category
some of them become serial rapists
most of them are like this though
they're mean most of them are sadists
you know yeah
um
they get off on one yeah yeah
um but they some of them are like dot
think that they're Don Juan
um BTK was kind of like that I think in
the end after he did his thing he'd like
to make him feel better and stuff well
you know unfortunately have to kill you
and it was a total dick but I think he
he thought he was being cool to him I
think such a gentleman such weird [__]
but uh they had one guy what the [__]
Dennis I had once they had one
um serial rapist
who got caught because one of the
victims was real quick thinking he was
friendly
yeah and after he was done
um she told her she says man the best
time I've ever had what's your number
and he gave and he he gave her his phone
number dummy yeah and she says good
thing about his criminals are stupid no
I was ego he believed her well yeah he's
like I'm all stupid she's like I'm gonna
call you can I call you back he's like
yeah yeah what's your phone number you
know I feel like yeah
and then he left and she [__] called
the police she goes I got that bitch's
phone number go get him yeah he got his
name and his phone number I think it was
just the first name and the cops
probably thought that [__] was hilarious
yeah so that was good wow what a dumbass
yeah
they got him and he raped a bunch of
women you're a young guy I mean the fact
that he can actually go out and rape
women who obviously don't want that and
then like be stupid enough to think that
a woman actually was like man that was
awesome I'm gonna call you back
I mean he thought he was Don Juan
evidently yeah I'm like wow that's uh
that's some weapons grade delusion right
there
yeah his whole thing if I remember
correctly uh you'd wake up the middle of
the night he was already on top you with
a knife whispering to you
[__] yeah trying to tell you to stay
calm and trying to talk all romantic
like he's like a Don Juan and [__] don't
you tell me to think yeah that will
punch you right in your face yeah trying
to be all smooth and everything
she got his number she figured out what
he was like he's like this [__]
got a huge ego yeah [__] if I ask for
his number you give it to me
yes that was that was good thinking
right there
I mean you can't blame the other women
for not thinking of that I probably
wouldn't have thought of that because
it's you know because of the trauma and
everything but the fact that she had the
wherewithal to actually keep her [__]
together and like figure that out I'm
like that's pretty awesome
but yeah so yeah so one of the one of
the women did say that he that Billy was
I mean they know he did it so it's not
like not like can say a legend
plus he's dead anyway
s but um yeah said he was so nice that I
would have considered dating him and had
the circumstances been different even
though like I said he raped her and took
her money afterwards so you know that's
nice and uh another thing
that people who um do actually believe
that Billy Milligan had uh did
and uh you know so was it aware of what
he was doing maybe because other
personalities were doing it
um point out that one of the rape
victims
said that he spoke in a German accent
uh and for the record he's from Miami
and his parents are American so he
doesn't have a German accent but we'll
get into that in a little bit
uh because that was another thing that
many of his personalities did some of
them had different accents so you know
so yeah so he did three rapes
um one on October 14th 1977 one on
October 22nd and the third one on
October 26th so like I said it was like
oh it was like a spree essentially
now the day after the third rape that he
did and they were all on campus and like
I said that he it was pretty much the
same Mo like he would just see a woman
he would essentially like kidnap her
from the campus like at gunpoint and
take her somewhere else like either in
the car or take her out of the woods or
something and then take all her money he
would usually like make her write him a
check uh and then cash it and then or
and and or he would take all her credit
cards so there was that because they
didn't have like ATM cards back then
which is crazy to think about but yeah
that we didn't
so the day after the third rape
um one of the victims was actually at
the police department and she was able
to pick Billy Milligan out of a bunch of
mug shots that they showed her because
it turned out Billy Milligan who in 1977
was 22 years old
had actually been convicted of rape
before
what happened was a year or two prior to
this I believe
um no actually it was more it was more
like five years because I think he was
only 17 because he was still a minor
so him and his friend had apparently
gone and picked up these two girls and
then these two girls later on had come
out and accused them of rape
now Billy's story in that instance
was that oh well they were actually
prostitutes and I couldn't get it up so
I didn't pay them and then they got mad
and reported us as rapists cops were
like [__] out of here that doesn't
happen yeah get the [__] out of here
with that story and so uh they did
actually get arrested but because they
were both miners they just went to juvie
or whatever but he had been convicted
before us we had a record
now uh he had also left his fingerprints
in the car in the car of one of the
victims and he had been in prison for
some other things uh like robbery you
know what I mean so he's like [__] like
that
so they actually
um found him like I said it was less
than two weeks after the first rape they
went to his house and arrested him
now interestingly when they arrested him
um the supervisor of the you know the
police investigations at the time when
he was reading uh Billy Milligan his
rights and was like going with him to
the police headquarters in Columbus Ohio
started to notice that Billy Milligan
was
not right like a little bit off
he said that the guy acted like he's
like you talk to him at different times
and it was like talking to different
people
at this point they didn't really know I
don't think anybody immediately jumped
to multiple personality but he seemed so
off uh it clearly he had some mental
health issues
that they were like um because you know
how you have to be like mentally
competent to stand trial right so in the
course of
getting him examined to see if he was
going to be mentally competent to stay
on trial like and this doesn't have
anything to do with like the later thing
where it's like you know Not Guilty by
reason of insanity they just want to see
if he's competent to stay on trial like
or if there's something to matter with
him so in the course of doing that and
because like I said a lot of
investigators and stuff noticed that he
wasn't quite right like he was strange
so they brought in a bunch of experts
and things like that to see if he was
going to be able to
stand trial you know what I mean
um but like I said a lot of people did
notice that maybe he wasn't right
now he didn't have any money so he was
assigned a couple of public defenders
whose names were Judy Stevenson and Gary
schweikart who actually represented him
for quite a long time
and
um after they started
bringing in psychiatrists
um
it slowly started to become clear that
maybe this dude had did
and as I said it's kind of hard to say
because
multiple personality disorders they
called it then was very much kind of a
Hot Topic at the time because Sybil had
just like the movie had just come out
like the year before it was a TV movie
but it was kind of a big deal everybody
was talking about it and so I kind of
feel like it was still very much in the
cultural consciousness
and what they determined from talking to
Billy Milligan and there a lot of the
interviews with him like with the
psychiatrists and stuff are in the
Netflix documentary and they're kind of
like interesting to watch
um I don't to me it doesn't seem like
all that compelling like it doesn't
really seem that different you know him
changing up and things like that but you
know it's just they only show like clips
of it so check it out and see what you
see what you think
but apparently what they determined
after talking to him after these
psychiatrists had talking to him
was that Billy Milligan himself
seemed completely out of it like he
seemed completely unaware he didn't seem
to know what he was being arrested for
he seemed like he was really scared and
it's like I don't really know what's
going on
and then it turned out allegedly
that the rapes and robberies had
actually been committed or so they
determined by two of his other
personalities and he was not aware of
what had been going on
and what they kind of figured out
afterward after they started talking to
some of his alleged other personalities
was that Billy Milligan the core
personality
um that they would often put him to
sleep that's what they called it like so
he didn't know what was going on and
then they would just run around and do
[__] now apparently Billy did complain
that he had time periods where he didn't
remember like he had black periods
blackouts which like I said is one of
the most important things you know uh if
you're starting out like on a road
toward getting diagnosed with
dissociative identity disorder that's
one of the first things they look for
it's like if you have these long
blackouts like if you wake up somewhere
like how the [__] did I get here like
you've lost days like you don't know
where you are and so that's kind of like
and you know and then you get reports
from other people said what the [__]
were you doing it's like I don't know I
would say you know what I mean so that
definitely has to be present
for that's to be one of the things that
has to be present for uh for the deaf
for that diagnosis and he apparently did
have that at least according to him
so he claimed that or at least some of
the other personalities claimed
that the robberies of the women because
remember I said he took their money and
stuff too
the robberies had actually been
committed by another one of his
personalities who was You're gonna laugh
he was a 23 year old Yugoslavian man
okay yeah named Reagan r-a-g-e-n okay
which must be a common name in
Yugoslavia I'm sure yeah with everything
that I read said that it was a it was a
combination of rage and again okay like
because I was like is there really
anybody I don't know how common that
name is and in uh Yugoslavia I know it's
not called you this live anymore but um
but yeah
so uh so he was the one that had done
the robberies however he was apparently
not the ones who had done the rapes
the rapes had apparently been committed
by another one of his personalities who
was a 19 year old lesbian okay named
adelana okay now apparently she was very
introverted and very shy and was seeking
human companionship and so thought the
best way to go about it was to take over
Billy Milligan's body and rape some
women because
that's how you do I guess yeah I'd have
to I'd have to consult with the uh with
the victims okay yeah you know what did
he say what happened you know was he
talking to you like he was a lesbian
something like that you know see I've
we'll see that's the thing I've heard
that one of the women did say that but I
don't know if that's true or if the
people are just like glomming that on
there like after the fact okay
Celtic Angel 73 says wow German and
Yugoslavia it's like the United Nations
of MPD yeah he had a couple of Brits in
there too which we'll get here but the
weird thing about it is that even though
one of the women said oh he was speaking
in a German accent but I don't think any
of his personalities were German so
maybe maybe it was the Reagan
personality talking because he did have
a very thick Slavic accent
because if you watch the Netflix
documentary like they show like um
there's a bunch of footage of him being
interviewed by the psychiatrist and the
cops and stuff and um he does go to like
that personality the Reagan personality
and like talks in a Slavic accent now
according to the book that was written
about him he could also speak
serbo Croatian
um but
I'm not entirely sure that I buy that
when we'll get into that in a little bit
because there have been a lot of claims
made about the amazing stuff that he
could do like in different personalities
like oh his IQ was different like in
each personality and he could speak all
these different languages like he could
speak Arabic like in one of the
personalities and not in the other ones
and I think I remember like other kind
of stuff like that and I'm not entirely
sure if I buy that and I think it's like
a little bit exaggerated
I'm just gonna say because there's
there's kind of mundane explanations for
some of the things
is is what I'm gonna say probably crappy
accents
well you know
um I'm not an exit I'm not an expert but
the Brit one of the British because I
think he had two British personalities
but the main British personality that he
had his name was Arthur
um he was spoke quite a bit like on the
Netflix documentary and it that sounded
pretty good I mean if you weren't really
um
I mean I if you were just like casually
listening to you wouldn't think oh that
was an American doing a British accent
you would just say think it sounded like
a British guy okay so I thought it
passed but like I said I'm not British
so there might be like other but to me
it sounded it sounded decent this Slavic
one I don't really know because I don't
know anyone with that particular I've
seen some old British movies where they
try to do an American accent and it
[__] sucks
a lot better at it
from The Walking Dead I thought he was
Southern
you fooled me yeah he did actually he
did actually but yeah so I mean his
British accent was pretty good I thought
I mean I I didn't notice anything like
uh bad about it
I didn't hear him talking in the other
British personality
but uh but yeah so that was kind of his
story and he was sticking to it
that two of the other personalities were
responsible for the robbery the
robberies and the rapes
and that Billy Milligan himself had no
knowledge of them because apparently as
I said the personalities would put him
to sleep like in the background and then
they would run around and do [__] and he
was apparently not aware of it he
claimed that he would often
like wake up in places and not figure
out how you got there when they um were
interviewing him like when the doctors
and stuff were interviewing him he
seemed and like and I I say seemed
because I don't know if it was real or
if he was faking I kind of suspect
faking but you know I wasn't there so I
don't really know but he did seem very
kind of freaked out and he seemed kind
of like surprised almost kind of like he
sort of like popped to himself and was
like where the [__] am I like who are
you people like all this other kind of
stuff I will say he if he was acting I
mean he was a good actor but
I don't know I I kind of suspect he was
faking but I don't know
so
um even though so okay so the
psychiatrists come to this conclusion
that he has this disorder now a lot of
the cops who were working on the case
are like that's [__] ridiculous it's
just that doesn't happen
but then some of the other cops now some
of the some of the other cops that were
working on the case and [__] like that
and like the prosecutors and everything
like they never believed it um you know
they said yeah he was good at it like
you know you could see you could see how
maybe he fooled people but some other
people were just like not bold however
some of the cops who were skeptical at
first when they sat and watched him and
listened to him like for extended
periods of time they're like yeah he
definitely did seem like he was kind of
going back and forth like in different
personalities and it wasn't just that he
had like different voices or different
accents they said that he had different
facial expressions different body
language like you would sit different he
would walk different he would do like um
you know all these different things that
made him seem like another person
so basically what ends up happening
so the defense attorneys that he had
somebody like I said they were public
defenders because you know he couldn't
afford an attorney
and they said well this is obviously
what we're going to use like as your
defense because you know what we can't
put you in prison because you weren't
there like it was some other personality
essentially using your body and you
didn't really know
what was going on so it wasn't really
you
so that's what they were uh gonna argue
now I will note that I kind of feel like
people maybe
have a
I think people maybe exaggerate how many
times like people have got off like Not
Guilty by reason of insanity it's very
very very very very
rare very rare
um a lot of criminals don't even attempt
it like are there lawyers are going to
attempt it just because it's almost
impossible to get to get up to a point
where
you know you're not legally culpable for
your crimes because of a particular
mental illness there's a reason though
okay the reason the reason why they
don't go for the insanity defense
because
in in essence The Punisher punishment
you're going to get through the insanity
defense is going to outweigh what the
prison system will get you
prison system will get you give you a
determinate
sentence that too in a a pretty good
environment a [__] Santa sounds
[__] you don't want to live in that's
pandemonium that'll [__] drive you
crazy and they're gonna dope you up man
there's no end time there's no way they
could just keep you in there like
forever it's life right it can be life
imprisonment basically
so they don't want that
they want to go to regular prison go
hang out with their buddies because
they're gonna well then they'll be out
maybe they'll be out in five ten years
and they know guys that are locked up
you know have relatives locked up a lot
of times and they're friends if they're
not if their friends aren't locked up
their friends will soon to join them in
the system
you know it's all locals
so you know if they're repeat customers
it's a scene like joining the Army
yeah and like I said it's so so that's
another because I you know I was gonna
add that that's like another
disincentive too I guess not only is it
really really hard to prove because you
can't just go in there and go I'm crazy
you know what I mean because you're
gonna have like a whole bunch of
different psychiatrists analyzing you
and you can't just be you can't just
have a mental illness and oh you're not
responsible they have to prove that you
don't know what you were doing was wrong
like you for example like you
legitimately believe I killed that
person because I legitimately believe
they were a demon you know what I mean
uh that's very very difficult difficult
to prove because it's subjective yeah
and so it's a lot of them don't even
attempt it because one like it's you're
probably not going to succeed because
everyone's just gonna be like no you
know what I mean you're just trying to
get out of it an American prison is
better than an American insane asylum
you don't go there oh
people yelling and screaming at all
hours
[__] throwing [__] the food's gonna
be worse
um you're not going to be free it's
going to be the same thing you're going
to be locked up yeah with a lot less to
do
no they're not gonna do that
so they don't try the insanity thing
murder Hornet said even if they deem you
insane they'll keep you in hospital
until you're fit for trial so you're
still [__] yeah yeah you can go back
like I said it's not like it's on a
state and I I kind of feel like maybe
some people have like a a misconception
that it's like oh Not Guilty by reason
if it's like oh well then you're free no
then they put you in a in a hospital
usually for the criminally insane which
is not a fun place either a lot of those
places are also hell holes yeah worse
worse than the penitentiary and like I
said there's no end game like you they
could just stick you in there and it's
like well we'll decide when you're well
enough if you're ever well enough to get
out of here and you might not ever be
you might just keep you locked up the
American Penitentiary system
it was Hazard has kind of a religious
base basis to it that started you know
in the early 1900s with panzram that
[__] Maniac panzeram who was raping
all those dudes yeah that guy was that
started the modern penetration
because the old the old prison system
was making dudes like pants around
so they kind of went went another way
they tried to make it almost kind of
like religious it's a place where you
would play pennants
and it was supposed to be a place of
paying for your sins but also
Rehabilitation so you could get out and
rejoin society as a productive member
so there was always at least some
attempt at keeping the guys mentally
healthy uh teaching them stuff
working them and you know and you don't
want to spend the rest you know 10 15
years in a [__] cell you'll go crazy
so they'd take him outside on chain
gangs and work them outside which kind
of would feel like freedom and they're
constantly moving well it was giving
them something to do they have to have
something to do and they have their own
little social ranking systems you know
and friends and [__] so
no it was
and another thing is is that you don't
want prison to be so bad that a dude is
willing to [__] fight the cops to the
death to avoid it you don't want that
that's why some of these some of these
uh
some of the sentencing mandatory
sentencing stuff is [__] ridiculous
that the sentencing needs to be left to
the judge between certain parameters
look like okay here's an example in this
case
he was pulling guns on women and taking
them into the bushes that's kidnapping
okay that was one of the charges that
didn't happen Okay and he was raping
them all right and then stealing from
him
in a place like Mississippi or Louisiana
Alabama
rape would probably carry about 15 years
but kidnapping carries life
yeah I think that's true of a lot of
States actually so if you're the rapist
why are you letting the woman live
because she can identify you right so
for to ensure your own Survival is
better if you kill her
which that's not good for society it's
better that the penalty isn't so high
that he's got well it's only 15 years
I'll let her live
if they catch me I'll just do some time
that's a much better solution then ah
life nah I'm not gonna do that pow yeah
like no and then she dies yeah you know
yeah and then you've killed it and you
killed innocent person with this [__]
sentence and then when the cops show up
he fights to the death and maybe kills a
cop or two
it's better to kind of Pat it out
give these guys something that they're
that they can do
so they don't fight to the death because
they're going to do what they're gonna
what they want to do you're not gonna
stop them they're they're already crazy
they're just gonna do it
I mean they'll do it if they're they'll
do it to face the death penalty they'd
still do it
that's well yeah they do they do it all
the time yeah
so he may as well leave it up to the
judge so he doesn't know how much he's
going to get
and you know when he's faced with cops
or having to kill somebody he goes you
know what
this may not be worth it I may not be
looking at a whole lot of time
and you want him in that position
well see that's the thing and I'm going
to argue that it's like you know other
than some outlier exceptions because
we've talked about like a lot of really
[__] up like serial killers and [__]
like that in the show and they should
probably just be taken out and skinned
alive and yeah they should be tortured
but that's not justice but but most of
the other people that were just like
crime and I'm not you know trying to
Discount like oh you know just like
Petty criminals stuff like that I mean
some of these people have done [__] up
[__]
but there's something to be said for
trying to rehabilitate them trying to or
at least give them something to do give
them some purpose give them a job inside
the prison give them but like you said
don't make it and I know that some
people they're like well you don't want
them to have like a cush life in there I
don't think they should have a cush life
like it should be easy but you know make
it like punishment but don't make it
like you said so bad that they will
fight to the death that it's gonna have
all these unintended consequences on
Society on innocent people I mean that's
you don't want that either you want them
to go quietly right
and uh that's what you want and people
don't realize how long 10 years is 15
years this dude does this [__] when he's
[__] 18 15 years later he's a totally
different person that's not really the
same person yeah you know I did [__] if
I could 17 said [__] at 17 18. I can't
even believe that I did that or said
that dumb as I was yeah well and that's
that's true of a lot of people yeah I
mean everybody did dumb [__] when they
were teenagers in their 20s and stuff
like that everybody I mean that's just
what you do and some people get addicted
to drugs they just [__] do shit's
real desperate yeah and you know
they may not necessarily in under normal
circumstances be a bad person they're
just being pushed into I gotta have this
or I'm going to get sick right type of
deal you know and I got no money and no
one will hire me I'm gonna steal it from
that liquor store I'm gonna steal money
right liquor store go buy some heroin
yeah that's a big see that that's what I
mean like that kind of crime it's still
crime obviously and it's like not to be
encouraged but there's a world of
difference between that kind of criminal
and like a deliberate like a serial
killer type of a serial rape who is just
going out doing that stuff because they
get off on it now most of the most in
the United States most of the violence
is drug related and the crime is most of
this drug most of the crime is drug
related but America did that to itself
yeah okay let's say you don't want
heroin you don't want cocaine you can
make it illegal but you can also control
it or you can make it legal and control
it
you shouldn't they shouldn't put I mean
at least decriminalized I would
decriminalize it and control it make a
control I mean if you must have it
illegal at least just have it be a
[__] fine or something like that I
would do I would control it maybe a
little bit more than alcohol some of
that stuff like when you have to
register yourself
yeah as a user or somebody's addicted to
this stuff and uh they'll just give it
to you
well that's what they were doing I don't
know if they still do it it's because I
know we have some British food but
that's what they were doing in the UK
that's a better solution because they um
you know because I had a former uh you
know of my ex-husband family who was a
heroin addict and you know she would
just go she had to go to the methadone
clinic like every so often and they
would just give her the stuff I I know
junkies though
or you know it's been a while but I knew
junkie's up in Boston they said the
methadone was worse than the heroin they
said you got addicted I have heard yeah
I've heard they were just like it's
because you can't patent heroin I guess
and there's probably government
contracts involved and [__] to come with
this methadone but they should have just
given the heroine
probably I might just yeah and to be
honest we've talked about this before it
just seems like you know I'm not heroin
addict can live a long time I'm not
saying that it's like oh everybody
should be like going around drugged up
to the eyeballs all the time but most
people don't want to do that it's like
you know alcohol is legal not everybody
drinks if you legalized a lot of that
and you it wouldn't change the usage
rates too much
no it wouldn't because anybody that
would want to do it is doing is already
doing it yeah
right so I kind of feel like oh maybe if
somebody like a small percentage of
people are curious It's like oh now
that's legal I'll do it but I just kind
of feel like if you wanted to do it you
would have done all kinds of addictive
stuff in other countries smoked opium
and stuff never shot heroin
I knew better than that one you can't
walk away from that one start a Coke
I could walk away from all that but some
people can't some people yeah it depends
on people's products
yeah yeah so
so you can't pretty much liked it all
uh but like I said we just next day
you're like yeah [__] that
you want you want cocaine the next day
but you go
you know that's a waste of money I never
bought it I always had to give it to me
so that's a waste of money I spending
that those [__] stupid girls to try
to give to because then they're trying
to sell to you we're gonna have cocaine
at least what you doing okay
there's a way to get around it okay what
you do is the following day when he says
man when you start thinking about you
know what maybe I should just go buy a
little bit of it
I'll buy a fifth of [__]
gin and get trashed you get trashed wake
up the next morning you won't you you'll
forgot all about it yeah
because especially if it's gin because
yeah
gin and tonics I love gin but man if I
drink any more than like three of those
I'm like because it's so acidic you know
yeah you get drunk you get drunk the the
uh the Earth the the the the the the the
desire for it goes away and then the
next morning you're kind of hung over
and you don't think good you think about
you I gotta [__] it you gotta go back to
work
I gotta make money hold on
so I never got hooked on it
yeah I mean like I said we've talked
about it before I just kind of wish I
still can't believe that weed is illegal
in some places that is just like
ridiculous well the reason why that God
the reason why that was made illegal I
think it was the early 1900s that they
did that
was because that was a product from
Mexico
and it was uh threatening the uh Saloon
sales of [__] beer and yeah a lot of
[__] that didn't have anything to do
with a lot of [__] it's illegal it's
nothing to really do with it nothing to
do with its effects with the morality of
it or anything like that or how bad it
is that [__] started off in California
and the saloons I think it was late
1800s is really when these or early
1900s when they started cracking down
they didn't want another product out
there competing with [__] beer and
whiskey that's all it was
well look at the same thing happened in
France with uh absence right where they
made up all kind of crazy stories about
absolute like that was the winemakers
did that because they because it was
cutting into their property yeah
absinthe is not
uh hallucinogenic it's not deadly it's
just a liqueur and it was just like any
other one it's a little stronger than
some but it's not and it makes the
difference and the proof's in the
pudding the reason why people were
drinking it because they they were
French and they'd come back from a war
it was the soldiers they were issued
that stuff as a water purification
ration they give it to them as a ration
and they put it they just put some of it
in the canteen and it would purify a
dirty canteen and they were drinking it
you're making like a jerk yeah
he loves it when I do this go get the
camera
put this up on the only thing like
you're doing a shake yeah yeah
ah it's getting dirty man uh what listen
Jenny's dirty I know yeah that's what
everybody knows that oh yeah never mind
we're doing a show he's he's getting
distracted again he's always getting
distracted yeah
you need to kind of like just focus
focus focus are you sure yeah okay yes
ma'am yes my lady
you want me to get you another drink uh
yeah okay might as well we still got a
little bit so we've only been on for an
hour it seems like we've been off for
like forever maybe but I don't know this
is like I said I'm having a good time on
this show so uh so yeah
so this is crazy to me but this is like
I said this is the only time that this
has happened in American legal history
um and okay now to be if I'm remembering
this correctly because didn't we do a
show pretty sure we did a show about the
Hillside Strangler or Hillside
stranglers because there was two of them
they were cousins but I think one of
those [__] tried to use the
multiple personality defense but it
didn't work
so it has been done before and it's not
real common however
in Billy Milligan's case it did work
um
they so they they had all these
psychiatrists and apparently all of them
that came in and examined him were like
for sure yeah he's got something
something's the matter with him now they
did I will note bring in Cornelia Wilbur
the same doctor that was that did the
civil case that like wrote the book
about civil like she well I mean they
had somebody else write it like a ghost
writer same thing but I mean she was the
one that
did the case study so Cornelia Wilbur
was brought in as a consultant
on this case and because she was seen as
like the expert in multiple personality
disorder so she was brought in and she's
in the um in the documentaries I mean
she's dead now too obviously but uh she
was on the documentary too like
interviewing
uh Billy Milligan and talking to him and
stuff like that so that's another reason
why a lot of people think the whole did
thing in his case in particular is
[__] because Cornelia Wilbur got
brought into it and I believe this was
quite a significant time before they
figured out that the whole civil thing
were Sybil you know Shirley Mason like
basically said yeah I made the whole
thing up like before Cornelia Wilbur was
well I was going to say before she was
um kind of disgraced but I don't think
she ever was because I think she died
before
it came out that all of that story was
kind of made up you know what I mean or
before it was public knowledge Maybe
so in Billy Milligan's case it worked uh
or at least they convinced the judge
that indeed
um Billy Milligan was not responsible
for the rapes or the robberies because
two of his altars to his other
personalities had actually done it
without his knowledge
so let's talk a little bit about
Billy Milligan's uh past and why if he
indeed does have this disorder or had
this disorder where it might have come
from now keep in mind that a lot of the
stuff about the abuse that he suffered
as a child
is from him but
um on the Netflix documentary there was
also interviews with his siblings uh his
brother he has an older brother and a
younger sister and they were both on
there they're both still alive and uh so
they were both on there talking and they
corroborated a lot of the stuff and
there was also some old like archival
footage of his mother talking about how
abusive The Stepfather was
so you know I don't know if if the abuse
was as egregious as Billy Milligan
claimed it was but apparently there was
abuse going on and Billy was generally
the target of it you know what I mean so
he and he definitely did have some
problems
so as I said he was born in Miami in
Florida 1955.
now his mom's name was Dorothy Sands and
she was a performer she was a singer
and his dad's name was Johnny Morrison
and he was also a performer he was like
a comedian like the vaudevillian type
comedian
now
when um he had so he they already had
one son who's in was Jim
and then they had uh Billy and then they
had a a daughter later on
whose name was Kathy Joe and like I said
Kathy Joe and Jim were both uh both on
the documentary
now interestingly their dad Johnny
Morrison
um was actually so had three kids with
their mom like obviously but he was
still married to another woman so it was
like an affair that he was having this
like this long-term Affair I think it
was like six or seven years that they
were together now Dorothy Sands prior to
getting into a relationship with this
dude had been in a relationship with
another guy named Dick Jonas
before this and he was kind of like a
violent alcoholic so she got the [__]
out of there this was like back in the
50s then she hooks up with this dude who
like I said she was kind of like the
woman on the side because he already had
another wife I don't know if he had any
other kids or not but he had another
family anyway and then he had a family
here uh with her
and Johnny Morrison
um Billy's biological father
was apparently
um I don't think he was necessarily
abusive
but he was for sure an alcoholic and he
suffered a great deal from depression so
he had his own like uh mental illness
issues
and he actually attempted suicide at one
point uh he actually took an overdose
and um his but his wife or uh Dorothy
found him and he recovered from that
however when Billy was I believe only
four years old
um his dad actually succeeded in
committing suicide he actually got in
this car and uh poisoned himself with
carbon monoxide
happened
Dorothy the mom she moved the kids back
to uh Ohio like uh Circleville Ohio that
was in 1960.
and then at which point she remarried
her first husband Dick Jonas who again
was like a violent alcoholic and then
divorced him again so like I said these
kids are going through a lot of uh dads
and one of him killed themselves and one
of him was a violent drunk so you know
what I mean
Faithfully
she marries a dude named Chalmer
Milligan
and they moved to Lancaster Ohio
now Chalmer Milligan was allegedly not a
drunk but allegedly I keep saying that
um
horribly horribly horribly abusive
particularly toward Billy
now Billy a lot of the stories that he
told about Chalmer some of which were
corroborated by his siblings
um you know because they talked about
what a piece of [__] Chalmer was Chalmer
denied it until he died
so and he was never charged with
anything so I don't really know what the
truth of the matter is
but Billy claimed that Chalmer would do
things like
um you know repeatedly beat him would
hang him from his fingers and toes damn
um would bury him alive like made him
dig his own grave and then buried him in
it and then like put a pipe down it and
then pissed in his face damn is it true
I don't know
um he was abusive for sure because it
wasn't just toward the kids like he beat
on the on the his wife as well and on
the other kids but to a lesser extent
Billy also claimed that once they moved
out to Chalmers Farm like he had a big
barn out in Lancaster Ohio
um that he would take him out to the
barn and rape him like sodomize him
um and like I said the the other
siblings did seem to corroborate this
they said that Chalmer was a piece of
[__] he was horrible he was abusive
um the older brother Jim who you know
he's obviously like a like an older man
now but he was being interviewed on the
Netflix documentary and he said that
Chalmer actually hug around that he
actually was responsible for getting rid
of Chalmer because one day
um Chalmer like flipped out and like
threw I do like threw Billy against a
wall or something like that and Jim the
older brother he actually like snatched
up a knife and like put Chalmer up
against the wall and said I'm gonna
[__] kill you if you don't get out of
here
um and so Chalmer left and it's like
because I think that Jim was like a
teenager at that point yeah that was too
dangerous to stay around and enrage
teenagers right and
um I will note too that they said that I
mean the sibling said that they knew
that there was something
I don't I don't they didn't necessarily
say something's wrong with Billy but
they knew that there was something
unusual about him like even from
childhood
um so they didn't really think anything
of it because you know this was like the
50s and 60s they didn't really know
anything about dissociative identity
disorder or anything like that they just
thought he was weird or eccentric or
something like that so they did say that
as a kid he would put on different
accents like act different but they just
thought that he was just being weird
like that was just like the what he was
like you know what I mean they said and
sometimes he would like you know sit in
the corner and like make buzzing noises
which one of his personalities did later
on which I think that personality was
named Sean who was like a five-year-old
kid or something like that
so there was some evidence that he had
not necessarily dissociative identity
disorder but he very clearly had
something you know mental health issues
like from childhood which if the stuff
about the abuse is true that tracks uh
because usually
people that that develop these types of
um pathologies these types of uh
illnesses it's usually because of
extreme
childhood trauma
uh because they dissociate you know just
to get themselves out of the situation
so they think that's probably where that
came from if indeed he does have that
so
basically
they think that his you know personality
just splintered
and
he seemed like a pretty troubled kid uh
he got suspended from Junior High
for basically he would go into weird
Fugue States and just kind of like
wander around
it didn't show up at class so like I
said he wasn't you know he wasn't right
like even from the start
um just [__] like that and he actually
got committed to a mental hospital
as a teenager also
now that was in Columbus and he was
diagnosed there with what they used to
call hysterical neurosis
I'm not sure entirely what this what
because they don't use that terminology
anymore I think that would be it's like
a conversion disorder or maybe like
narcissistic personality disorder
something like that
um it seemed like a lot of the diagnoses
he got like as a younger person were
more like along the schizophrenia type
of uh type of Route so like I said he
definitely did have issues like mental
health issue he wasn't making that up
now so he gets sent to this Hospital in
Columbus where he's diagnosed with
hysterical neurosis
and he was only there for three months
and got kicked out the mental hospital
for being disruptive and I'm kind of
like well
what isn't that what a mental hospital
they're supposed to be helping the
people right I mean yeah you would think
a lot of them would be disruptive and
that was kind of like you would expect
that I have no idea what they're talking
about I don't really I don't know either
so I'm like how bad does your behavior
have to be to get kicked out of a mental
health facility it must not have been
like a high security I guess not and
just some little like
like [__] Treatment Center
but you would think they would like oh
this motherfucker's crazy he's got to go
deeper into this system
Maybe not maybe maybe he was just
disrupted by making you know joking
around and making fun of you know maybe
it wasn't violent yeah maybe I'm not
real sure they just said it but like I
said you'd have to be like pretty
disruptive I would think like to get
thrown out of a mental health facility
but it depends I don't know I don't know
if this was just kind of one of those I
think it was probably some [__]
thing one yeah maybe it wasn't like a
hardcore type place I mean it's a state
mental hospital you think but I don't
know I'm sure there's a bunch of
different divisions of it it might have
been a voluntary treatment type thing
counseling yeah and they were like yeah
we don't want to deal with this
[__] yeah get out of here
so yeah so he gets kicked out of there
now he does actually end up going to
high school for a little while but he
also got kicked out of high school in
1972 he was expelled
for being again disruptive and not
really getting with the program
and in 1972 or 1973 he joined the Navy
he was only in the Navy for a month
before they kicked him out didn't make
it through basic he probably no yeah
um because like I said he's not he's not
a well person you know what I mean and a
lot of people seem to notice that
so that same year uh is when the first
rape incident occurred that I mentioned
earlier like if like a friend and him
and a friend they were I believe they
were 17 and they picked up some women
and then you know allegedly raped them
and then said that
you know owe their prostitutes and I
couldn't get it up and like so I didn't
pay them and then they got mad at me and
reported but you know try to lie as we
have yeah try to lie his way out of it
so again like the cops the judge so that
they didn't buy that story
um and so he and his friend were both
found guilty of rape but because they
were minors uh they only served or Billy
only served six months in a like a youth
camp type of thing
now after Billy Milligan was released
from this Youth Camp
Apparently one of his other
personalities at least according to the
book that was written about him
uh took over and I believe this was
Reagan the the Yugoslavian Servo
Croatian man
so this guy starts kind of working as
like a low-level criminal he's kind of
like working as a bodyguard I guess for
like a drug dealer you know what I mean
and apparently this is another
personality's word but and I want to get
into too because his reg the Reagan
personality who's the one that was
supposedly robbing the people if not
raping them
um the the story went around that Reagan
could actually speak serbo Croatian
um now Daniel Keys who wrote the book
about him the minds of Billy Milligan
like I said he was the same guy that
wrote Flowers for Algernon back in the
day which is a huge success and like I
said I read that in school and it's a
really good book
that was fiction though
but
um
so that so he said it's like yeah he
would talk to me in serbo creation or he
would write me letters and I had to like
send them out and be translated
however uh one of the it was either one
of the psychiatrists or one of the or a
detective or something like that could
actually speak serbo Croatian
and so started talking to him in it and
then he would flip into a different
personality okay conveniently right
so not sure I buy that because I think
it went around that it's like oh my God
he speaks all these other languages that
he doesn't know he's pretending but I
think maybe he was bullshitting yeah
because there's a thing too where his
one of his British personalities Arthur
who was kind of like one of the main
guys which I'll get into in a little bit
but um he could apparently he was
British but he could apparently speak
Arabic but they found out later on that
what he did was that another inmate at
the hospital he was at could speak
Arabic and he asked him to like write
letters for him they found out later on
and they actually mentioned that in the
Netflix documentary too
so yeah so right around this time what
so elements of this [__] he's faking it
yeah certainly I mean that's what I'm
saying I kind of feel I'm not saying he
wasn't mentally ill he absolutely was
right I'm just saying I don't know if I
buy that he had all these personalities
and he didn't know what they were up to
that he wasn't like responsible for him
like I think he absolutely knew what he
was up to
and he just used that as an excuse to
get out of but yeah and I'm not saying
he didn't have mental illness because he
clearly did and they said that like even
as as a child that he had something
wrong with him
so uh in about 1974
um he was again uh kind of arrested for
you know petty crime I guess he was like
at a rest stop and I guess he was
approached by two men who are like uh
who were dressed as women and he I don't
know if they were soliciting or if they
were just walking by or whatever but he
apparently like beat them up and took
their purses and like took all their
money
so he did that kind of [__]
now one thing about Billy Milligan that
I think is kind of interesting is he's
actually a very accomplished artist like
if you see a lot of his artwork it's
actually very good
and he would do artwork as different
personalities like as time went on and
that that became a bone of contention
later on like when he became sort of
like a little bit of a celebrity because
he started selling his artwork like he
would sign them with his different
personalities and stuff like that and
people were mad because he's a criminal
and he's making money off of
yeah they didn't want him to like make
money off of his artwork essentially
like while he was in the mental hospital
because they thought it wasn't right
because you know he raped people
and maybe killed people but that was
like later on
so I think they even maybe passed a
statute I don't know if it was just Ohio
or [__] but I think they even called it
Milligan's law or something like that
where it's like you weren't allowed to
they wanted to keep criminals from
benefiting from like for example writing
a book about themselves and like making
a [__] ton of money on it you know what
I mean because I kind of feel like
people are uncomfortable with that and
understandably so
so
um 1975 uh he actually did a drugstore
robbery
and uh so yeah he got arrested for that
as well so like I said he had a record
so for that particular robbery
he got two years in prison but he got
paroled in April of 1977 and six months
later is when the rapes on the Ohio
State University campus happened
so because you know after the rapes
happened and he was caught and then they
basically the judge ruled judge flowers
that was his name
he ruled that um yeah he does have these
multiple personalities according to all
these psychiatrists and it's like he
wasn't aware of what his other
personalities were doing so therefore
he's not responsible so like I said they
didn't let him free but they're like
we're gonna put him in a mental health
center now the one that they were gonna
I think they were gonna send him up to
the one maybe I think it's further
criminally insane maybe but it's like up
in Lima I think in Ohio but because that
place is kind of had a really bad
reputation for being like a total
[__]
um they actually petition for him to go
to sort of like a slightly nicer mental
health facility which in in Athens Ohio
now
one of the things that and I kind of
feel like this is still in the popular
Zeitgeist nowadays when people talk
about dissociative identity disorder is
that and I think this is almost entirely
from Dr Cornelia Wilbur of this idea is
that you cure the patient by fusing all
their personalities back into one
personality
and um you know basically that's how she
said that she treated Sybil and again I
don't know if I buy that or not but
that's kind of what she was trying to do
in this case as well and it's kind of
funny because like on the Netflix series
I think she thought that you could just
do it by like Fiat you would just like
say hey fuse this personality and that
personality together do it do you know
what I mean and I'm like oh okay that
was easy you know what I mean it's like
because she did actually I think he
should fuse what I'm trying to remember
like he had one cup named Danny and one
named Tommy or something like that why
don't you use those two together you
know what I mean
so okay so initially
when they were first examining him they
determined that at first he had 10
personalities
now the main one like I mentioned was
now you got you had Reagan who was kind
of like the muscle of the group and he
was the the robber guy
and he was also kind of like he wasn't
entirely a bad person apparently but he
was like the kind of the protector of
the group
then you had kind of your main sort of
Master of Ceremonies type character who
is Arthur now he was like the British
guy
and Arthur he was apparently the one who
would control
who got
what he called the spot now if you've
seen the M night uh Shyamalan movie
Split uh you know with James McAvoy
great movie
um that character that he plays is based
on this guy
and he uses similar terminology I
believe in the movie Split he says uh
when one of the other personalities
takes over he says they're gonna take
the light like the spotlight
um Billy Milligan would say take the
spot but it's it's the same thing he's
he's based on him
I was asking if he had fetal alcohol
syndrome no he had accepted he had
exceptional intelligence about 130 IQ so
fetal alcohol yeah gonna be a lot
reduced
reduced IQ
yeah that's that's a very common symptom
of fetal alcoholism the thing about
I've read to you that Billy Milligan
because they said as evidence of that he
actually did have did they're like well
they gave him IQ tests like when he was
in different personalities and he scored
differently
but I feel like that would be
I was I was listening to the um
the Casual criminalists show about this
and he made a good point he's like well
you know you can't fake a higher IQ but
it'd be pretty easy to fake a lower one
because he's like the the IQ test that
they gave him ranged from 69 which is
like borderline you know mentally
challenged up to 129 which is basically
what his IQ was he couldn't go no higher
than that even though Arthur the main
one said that he was a genius but he
didn't take the test see but the other
personalities did but he's like it would
be pretty easy to take it it's like you
could just do your regular intelligence
but then you could just like [__] it up
and be like hey I'm a dummy like it's a
different personality you know what I
mean so like I said there's there's ways
to get around it
it's pretty easy to like just [__] the
test up and make them think that you're
stupid and you're a different person
yeah you can't [__] it up and make them
think you're smart and make you think
you're smarter than you are yeah you
can't do that it's about solving puzzles
yeah you could either solve those
puzzles or you can't yeah or you just
get real lucky and it's multiple choice
I guess that could happen but you know
I've taken it twice it's not multiple
choice that's what I'm saying it would
have to be like multiple choice and
you'd have to get really lucky and if
they're not they're evaluating
everything about you not only your
answers but like uh how you answered it
and questions that you asked or any you
know what I mean they eval it's a
holistic
judgment basically and where they put
you
I did good
yeah I didn't do it I did good yeah I
usually took one when I was younger that
was actually given to me by a
psychiatrist like in person it wasn't
like a written yeah
yeah scholar graduated what I was Sao
Paulo you had to you had to do that that
was just part of it that was expensive
School
State Department sent me there I was as
independent my mother was in the Foreign
Service you had to take that IQ test
they want to know
but that's a that was a very expensive
Brazilian International Private School
uh okay so where was I all right so
um yeah
so the 10 and then you had um I was
talking about the ten personalities
that's right so Arthur he was the one
that controlled who got control of the
spot like which personality could come
out at which time
some of the other personalities that
were in the original 10 were
um there was the the lesbian woman who
was 19 who was the rapist there was a
kid whose name was I think his name was
Alan and he was 16 and I think he was
the one that was like supposedly like a
really good like escape artist like he
could get out of um like straight
jackets and [__] like that like some
Houdini [__]
um like I said I don't know if that's
true or not but that's kind of the thing
that they always say Arthur they say the
British guy he was also like real into
they called me he was very spock-like
they said he's very rational and he was
like real scientist like he knew a lot
about science and medicine and stuff
like that but like I said that's
something you could learn there was also
a couple of personalities that were
children and they were you know one was
like a three-year-old dyslexic girl
uh one was like a four-year-old boy that
would just kind of sit and Buzz all the
time and they're presuming like I said
if this is a real diagnosis that these
were the first
splintered personalities that formed
like from the trauma
that he experienced when he was a kid
now while he was in Athens in the
hospital
the thing about it was that because he
was such an anomaly from a psychiatric
standpoint
and because his case had been so widely
covered by the media because it was the
first time that anybody had used this as
a defense and it worked you know what I
mean so he was It was kind of reported
on all over the place so he kind of
became a little bit of a celebrity
and For Better or For Worse his
celebrity status and because his doctors
seem to think that maybe he wasn't
dangerous even though hello he raped
some people
um they kind of just let him walk around
loose a lot of the time like he was
supposed to be confined in this mental
hospital but they would let him go like
on unsupervised
furloughs like yeah sure you can go on a
drive to here or there you can do this
that and the other thing which
uh they got a lot of criticism for that
because you know a lot of people did
kind of feel sorry for him after they
heard about all the abuse and that he
had these mental health issues and
people were willing to give him the
benefit of the doubt but then on the
other hand a lot of women were like hey
we don't want him walking around our
street because like he's a rapist so
that's kind of not cool you know but
like I said because he was famous
he just kind of got away with it any
kind of got in the habit of sort of
being treated like a celebrity who kind
of like acting like one a little bit too
now as he was at this Hospital
uh it so happened that because like I
said they they determined at first that
he had 10 personalities but then it
turned out that there was another 14 of
them hiding in there these personalities
were supposedly called the undesirables
and these were the ones that Arthur
would not allow to come out
now some of these personalities that
were and there weren't undesirable for
any like that like they were violent or
anything like a couple of them were but
most of them were just undesirable
because
um Arthur didn't think that they had any
point to them I guess because like one
of them was like a little boy that was
deaf
um you know and he's like oh we never
let that one come out one of them was
like an Orthodox Jewish guy
for some reason well I think his I think
um
I think the biological that he was the
only one that was religious I think his
name was Samuel or something like that
that personality might have to perform
some some circumcisions yeah I think he
was the only religious one like the
other none of the other ones were
religious but I think his biological
father was Jewish maybe that's where
that came from
but the 24th personality interestingly
was called was simply called the teacher
now the weird thing about this like I
said is that you know the the kind of
um overarching uh thing with that
Cornelia Wilbur came up with it's like
oh the way you treat these people is you
have to fuse all their personalities
back into like one core personality but
the weird thing about this is that the
the personality of his that was
allegedly just called the teacher was
pretty much already fused because the
teacher was kind of like all of the
personalities like rolled into one
except not Billy you know what I mean I
don't know it's just kind of complicated
like I said I kind of don't know if this
is like real or not you know it sounds
it sounds outlandish and I know that
human brains can do weird ass [__] it
wouldn't shock me if this was a real
thing
but I think if it is a real thing it's
probably like super super rare and I'm
not really sure if this guy had it I
think this guy was just mentally ill but
maybe kind of like jumped on this
bandwagon to avoid responsibility for
[__] well I want to say this
that MK Ultra thing that the CIA was
working on part of that was some German
technology
that we got through uh Operation
Paperclip
and um I remember when I was a kid when
this they showed this on television this
big hearing and they swept it under the
rug
evidently in Germany
um back during the 40s
when the uh mustache man and his boys
took over they were looking at the
uh what do you call them orphanages
and they had doctors Nazi doctors in
those orphanages and they were finding
these kids with uh multiple personality
disorder they saw it
and then and they
tried to figure out what was causing it
and they said it was caused by
Early Childhood sexual trauma
yeah but she was he's that's what
happened to him yeah
so these guys who were experts at it
evidently
and in Germany they were taking children
and molesting them and torturing them
in secret in these uh
uh
clandestine facilities to turn these
kids into multiples they were forcing
them into into being a multiple
they were orphans that they were doing
they were doing this too the idea was is
to turn them into sex operatives and
assassins
some of the some of the men some of the
personalities were a sex operative and
some of the personalities were supposed
to be an assassin so you could send this
little kid at a dude
and and talk and that that little girl
would talk that dude into having sex
with him and they would do it in a place
where they they were waiting
and they take pictures of it and then
they can run that dude on remote control
with those pictures after that and if
they had any problems with him
she could they could send that little
girl to go or get on another Target they
would send that little girl out to go
kill somebody
it was the little girls mostly some boys
I guess
evidently we got These Guys these guys
that could these
German doctors psychologists [__] they
were they were from the they were from a
German
basically secret weapons programs you
know what I mean it was part of the
intelligence agencies
and we got this technology we're using
it here in the United States and there
were some women that came forward in
front I remember back in the 80s
they were
talked about the abuse that they
suffered to Congress at the hands of
these subcontracted
psychologists it was government money
behind it or something then they
switched it under the rug and never
heard about it again but I saw it on
television I remember it
was maybe some of you guys might know
what I'm talking about maybe we could
find that case again
but it had something it was one of the
divisions or one of the little branches
that MK Ultra was doing
it all sounds awful [__] familiar
with these [__] child islands and all
this kind of stuff it was like that
uh they do they use this as a technology
in the intelligence agencies
sick they're [__] sick man evil [__]
yeah it's an orphan that's a human being
you know evidently they were keeping him
in cages
uh depriving of stuff
sexual abuse get forcing them into
becoming multiples kind of like you know
how they said he's making that boy
pretending to bury that boy alive and
pissing down in the [__] breathing
they're doing [__] like that to these
girls and they were little
five six
it was called
trauma-based mind control that came from
Pavlov
with the damn dogs that were in the
cages yeah and the uh the River
overflowed
and the dogs nearly drowned inside the
cages and they had to go in there and
pull the Dogs Out Underneath the water
to get them out of the cages and those
dogs forgot everything that they had
been teaching them they realized that
you could do pattern a person using
trauma
and then that it was confirmed we talked
about on the MK Ultra show they had one
of those contracted guys up in Canada
psychologist that was erasing those
women's Minds using LSD and
um what was it
put them in solitary confinement for a
year
with LSD and [__] running the dam
recordings through the earphones when
they come out they were just infantile
remember we talked about that yeah
so they do this kind of stuff
it's weird
Mr 88 says a casual criminalist Simon
Whistler is great yeah I love Simon
Whistler he's like he's got like a whole
bunch of different shows he's got like
casual criminals is good he has one
about like unknown like Mysteries he has
like a history one where he talks about
like historical figures he's really good
like he's really funny yeah
um the reason why I was bringing that up
is because
what's being described here in this case
is a reality I just don't know if he was
like I said I don't know if he was one
of them that's what I'm saying I'm not
saying uh you know I'm not a
psychiatrist I'm not an expert in the
[__] I don't know if it exists I think
if it exists
um it wouldn't shock me it is outlandish
but the human mind is a weird place and
weirder [__] has happened I'm just
saying if it does exist it's probably
much rarer than you would think because
I think for a time because Zach is
saying it's like you know suddenly
becomes trendy I think it was trendy for
a time because of Sybil and because of
other things that people were kind of it
was very much in the cultural
Consciousness at the time so I kind of
feel like a lot of people maybe got
diagnosed with it when maybe they had
other issues that didn't have and I'm
not saying that Billy Milligan didn't
have mental health issues he absolutely
did and I'm not saying that he didn't go
through horrible abuse as a child
because I imagine he probably did um at
least according to his other family
members uh his stepfather was a real
piece of [__]
so even though you know the stepfather
denied ever doing anything but of course
he's going to he's not going to admit it
is he but um you know I'm just I'm just
saying I don't know in this particular
case if he actually did genuinely
have did or if he was just using that as
a convenient way to avoid responsibility
for things I'm not saying that he's not
mentally ill because he was but I'm just
saying I don't think I don't know if it
was that particular thing and it's not
it seems not really clear because I've
seen I've seen both things they seem to
suggest on the Netflix documentary and I
could be Miss maybe I misheard this but
they seem to be suggesting that he was
not aware
of the other personalities until after
they caught him and then they started
like playing tapes for him like back and
telling him about it like he seemed to
know kind of that there was but he
seemed alarmed when
because he said something to the effect
of of oh is that the people that these
ladies that lady says live inside me
like almost like he didn't know about it
like what are they doing in there
so
from everything that I've read it seemed
like his other alleged personalities
knew about one another
but he didn't know about them but I
don't know if maybe I misheard that or
misread or something like that because
it doesn't really seem clear whether he
knew
that he had other personalities
and they were just like doing [__]
because he did complain about having
like amnes or like missing time which
like I said is is one thing that they
look for when they look for that
diagnosis when you you know you wake up
days later and you're somewhere and you
don't have any idea how you got there
because one of your other personalities
was driving essentially Ben frail's in
there saying that what I was talking
about he said he's saying it may be
operation Monarch I might have to look
into that
at the Soviet Union and the United
States was both working on that damn
technology with making those kids into
multiples
yeah
yeah I mean for something like because
like I said you're what you're
essentially what you were trying to do
is
you're trying to encourage dissociation
yeah so to encourage dissociation you
would have to do something really really
really horrible that's what they were
doing to them
you know evidently they got it so they
would just check it out yeah
they got the idea from the Germans that
saw it happening in orphanages yeah
I mean this is [__] up man yeah
[__] up
so uh so yeah
so as I mentioned uh you know because
Milligan was in the hospital and they
were giving him a lot of privileges
uh people were didn't really love that
and like I said it really did seem like
because it was so big in the media at
the time like a lot of people were
complaining they said it was faking or
you know you know he shouldn't be
running around loose because he's
clearly a rapist so they shouldn't be
giving him all these Privileges and
letting him run around
um you know they would let him go like I
said they would let him sell his artwork
and make money and it's like they would
let him drive around like he had a party
at the hospital now apparently uh
and this should have probably surprised
no one
but evidently he I don't know if it was
full-on sexual assault but he did get
into trouble
at the Athens mental hospital for
uh attacking molesting something like
that some of the other
patients the the women patients which
I don't know why they were letting him
run around loose like I said but uh
that's what happened
so he did eventually get sent up to
the uh other
uh mental hospital Lima state hospital
for the criminally insane which like I
said they didn't want to send him there
at first because they thought it was a
[__]
um but he acted bad at the at the nicer
one so they eventually did end up
sending him up there
um and not surprisingly yeah Billy
didn't love it up there he called it a
chamber of Horrors
uh that hospital eventually uh became a
prison in 1980 and so Billy was
transferred to yet another place uh the
Dayton forensic Center and then he was
sent on to the central Ohio psychiatric
hospital
and
through this time it seems as though
because he was being bounced back and
forth through like to different Mental
Hospitals for about like a period of
like seven or eight years
and like I said in the early days he did
have a lot of privileges like they kind
of just let him walk around like
unsupervised a lot of the time
but evidently after the seven or eight
years and after going back and forth
from hospital to hospital
um they determined that probably uh his
personalities had pretty much all fused
and he was no longer a danger to society
now they didn't let him out not quite
yet
he got transferred back to Athens the
original mental hospital
um and he was in there for a little
while and then I believe that they let
him out in 1988 although he was still
under like supervision until 1991.
however there were some uh bumps in the
road
um for example
there was uh there was a time where he
was
in Athens and he was like driving a
truck because like I said they kind of
just let him run around loose and
somebody in the truck with him like was
shooting at people randomly like out so
I'm just like that's great
um now while he was in the central Ohio
Psychiatric Hospital in 1986 he actually
escaped from there
and he left a bunch of videotapes for
like for the news outlets and stuff at
the bus station in Columbus and he was
like complaining about how shitty they
were to him at the hospital like how
he's being treated bad so there was that
um and for a time actually with the help
of his brother Jim because he actually
talked about this extensively like on
the Netflix show but he actually ran
away to Washington State to Bellingham
and he opened a business there like a
hot tub business with two other guys
like you do and he went under a
pseudonym like he changed his name
because it was you know you could do
that a lot easier back then he got new
ID like he got a new social security
card and everything like that under the
name Christopher Carr and he was just
like under a total different identity he
started a business and everything
and so he's like running around the
[__] country so he was in Washington
state for a while and then like he went
down to California for a little while
and then like he went to Miami
um and the thing about it was that for a
while
back in 1990 I believe it was like 1990
or 1991.
uh because he was kind of famous and he
was doing like run around in California
even though he escaped from a mental
hospital for Christ's sake and he was
run around the country loose James
Cameron was Ascent was wanted to make a
movie about him and he met with him damn
like they even went to Ohio together I
think Cameron James Cameron like in 1991
like he was gonna he was gonna buy the
rights to the story
and he was gonna make a movie about it
he was apparently like really really
stoked
and he like met him and he was like run
around and they said that for a long
time
um Billy was like kind of living the
Hollywood lifestyle man like he was down
in Hollywood like and he had all this
money suddenly and like babes yeah like
hot babes like a nice car and like all
this other kind of [__] and um but it
turned out what happened
was that this other woman who I guess
had written or had co-written uh I don't
remember if it was the Daniel Keys book
or if it was something else but she came
out and said that she actually had the
rights to Billy Milligan's story and
that she and that James Cameron or that
the production company I think it was
Fox would have to pay her like 1.5
million dollars and fox was like nah and
James Cameron's like nah not worth it so
that whole project fell through now I
believe later on I think in like 2014
2015 they were gonna make a a movie
about him called the crowded room and
Leonardo DiCaprio was gonna be in it but
I think that fell through too however
I think they're still gonna do like a
fictional I think it's a series now and
I think they are actually shooting it at
this point and Tom Holland uh otherwise
known as like the new Spider-Man uh he's
playing Billy Milligan I think it's only
just going to be Loosely based on him
though I don't think it's gonna be like
super like hardcore
so yeah so this [__]
he gets transferred all these
psychiatric hospitals they give him all
these Privileges and he escapes anyway
now after he escaped
in 1986 what seeing when's the time to
do commercial break well okay you got
time okay yeah we just you know I mean
we can't be on too much longer because I
gotta go to bed soon it's like quarter
past we'll re-ditch it well I know
that's what I'm doing we got to play
commercials though too well do you want
to do commercials now do commercials now
and then we'll go back okay we'll do
some commercials people all right and
then we'll be back in a few minutes
because like I said I don't have too
much left because you know I gotta get
up early tomorrow so I don't want to go
too long but yeah all right so we're
gonna do a couple commercials and then
we'll be
right back in just a second
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're back again I actually
have a little bit less left than I
thought because it's like there's a
couple pages but I already said all that
stuff so so I'm just I just got like
this one below page here
so um so yeah
so he's [__] loose and running around
now in 1986 I believe when he was in
Bellingham Washington and Mr 88 just
pointed out something really interesting
that I had totally forgotten about
Bellingham Washington Kenneth Bianchi
who is one of the hillside stranglers uh
he who also faked multiple personalities
like he tried unsuccessfully to pull
that [__] at his trial he committed his
last murders in Bellingham that's right
he did so there's another [__] link
up right there because like I said he
also tried to do that whole uh multiple
personality thing but didn't work in his
case Jen Allen says I love when one
channel I watch uh shouts out another
Channel I watch I'm assuming she means
like when I was talking about
Simon Whistler yeah I love that guy he's
awesome I was like I was actually
listening to uh his show about this on
my in the car on the way home from work
today and it was like funny as [__] it
was like an hour long
so in 1986 I believe when he was in
Washington you know after he had escaped
and everything
and while he was going under the Alias
Christopher Carr
he had he lived in an apartment with a
roommate
um whose name was I think Michael Madden
now Michael Madden
was last seen
on September 15 1986.
and has not been seen since he
disappeared
interestingly the last time he was seen
Alive by their landlord
he and Billy were arguing
also after Michael Madden disappeared
Billy because they had a joint account
like because they had a business or
something like that Billy
um cashed a couple of Michael Madden's
disability checks yeah he killed him and
sold his car yeah he killed him claiming
that oh he owed me some money so this is
just kind of like well yeah everybody is
pretty sure allegedly that he killed it
sounds like he killed Mike yeah they
even had like cops on Netflix called
yeah we're pretty sure he killed that
[__] like they don't know but
they don't have any proof they don't
have a body now they said that they did
find
um either in the apartment or where was
it I can't remember where it was now I
think it was in the apartment but they
did find Michael Madden or no like in a
suitcase that or a box or something that
um
that some of um Billy's [__] was in
um they found a pair of glasses which
looked very much like the glasses that
Michael Madden wore and the lenses were
busted out of them and there was a
little bit of blood on them but
obviously like not enough blood that you
would you'd know that the person was
dead and they never did find the body
um but they don't know where that dude
is but like I said that's
you know they didn't have a body so they
couldn't do anything maybe who he was
maybe or or I kind of feel like because
a bunch of people said that
um and even people that knew him people
that talked him like his family members
um his brother and sister were very you
know because they talked to them
extensively on the Netflix show they
were very sympathetic toward him but
they knew that he had problems and
they're like and they're not excusing
his behavior they're like we're like we
know that he had mental illness and we
know that he was treated horribly and
stuff like that but that doesn't excuse
like all the [__] that he did and they
both said and a bunch of people that
knew him said that he was very
manipulative and that's kind of like
something that he would do was that he
would kind of like wangle his way into
your life and then like start taking
your money and like all this other kind
of stuff so they think that maybe what
happened with the roommate
because the roommate was a veteran was
like a military veteran and was disabled
um I'm not sure what the disability was
but they got like disability checks
right so they got that every month and
um and he would cash them like and he so
he was basically like taking the dude's
money so they speculate that maybe the
dude was like Hey where's my check or
you know why are you taking my money and
then maybe he's like well maybe I should
just bump this dude off and take all the
rest of his [__] because then like after
he was gone like he sold his car and all
this other kind of stuff and got money
with it now notably it's it's weird
because they mentioned this on the
Netflix documentary but I didn't see any
other videos mention it they think that
he might have killed another guy too uh
whose name was Dewan but I can't
remember what his last name was but he
was like a friend of his evidently
and that guy disappeared too and they
never did find that dude's body either
and they knew they suspected that Billy
maybe had something to do with it
because they knew they were acquainted
but they didn't have any proof in that
case either so that's two murders that
he's suspected of and interestingly
before he died uh they had his I believe
it was his niece and she was talking on
the show and she said that he told her
before he died he's like you know do you
think she said that he said something
like do you think that God can forgive
someone like me and she's like sure you
know God can forgive anybody and he's
like well I've done really bad things
like I've killed two people okay like
apparently he told his niece that
according to her
so there's that
now as I mentioned he was released from
Athens the hospital in 1988 but he was
still like being monitored like they did
catch him again like because he was
running around the country but they
caught him again like they caught him in
Miami
and they put him back in the hospital
for a little while but he was just under
supervision like he was like an
outpatient type of thing like he just
had to come in every so often but then
in 1991 evidently even though I mean
he's still a rapist and even though they
kind of suspected but couldn't prove it
that he had maybe killed at least one
and possibly two people they determined
that he was no longer a danger so 1991
they basically just like let him out and
they didn't you know and he didn't have
to go in for like for checkups anymore
anything like that and for that time
period like he disappeared for a while
they don't know where he was like during
all that time
for it's maybe like a decade
now it turned out that his sister Kathy
Joe she had um a house with a little bit
of land and she was kind of worried
about him like I said she's a sister you
know and she bought like like a trailer
and she put it on her land and he
apparently like lived in it like for the
last week because he got diagnosed with
cancer
in 2012.
and um so he lived in this trailer like
with her and her family uh for the last
couple years of his life I believe he
died in 2014 uh when he was 59 years old
and he looked
pretty bad like at the end because they
did share some pictures of him
but so yeah as I mentioned
um you know Daniel Keys wrote a book
about it and he wrote like another
follow-up book called The Milligan Wars
and that was published in 1994.
uh but was not published in the United
States like it was published in a bunch
of other countries
but the thing about it was that I guess
it wasn't released in the U.S because
there was some litigation about
um again Billy Milligan uh getting money
for selling painting selling book rights
selling that kind of thing there was
like all kind of controversy about that
and the weird thing about it too was
that after he got out
even though I mean okay technically he
was sent there like at trial like he was
sent to a mental health facility right
because they're like okay Not Guilty by
reason of insanity so you go to a mental
health facility later on the state of
Ohio was trying to like make him pay for
all of the time that he had spent in
mental health facilities which seems a
little weird so they were trying so he
had to declare bankruptcy like later on
because they said he owed like a half a
million dollars or something like that
like from all the and I'm just like I
never heard of that ever
like usually if they send you there
you'd think that we'll
it's on their dime I would think you
know what I mean it's not like I just
went there and I would pay for it but I
don't know like obviously nobody ever uh
paid ever nobody paid for it because he
didn't have the money
so uh yeah so as I mentioned uh James
Cameron was gonna make a movie about it
that never worked out but I believe that
they are making a series that's kind of
loosely based on him with Tom Holland
and as I mentioned the M Night Shyamalan
movie Split from 2016 uh the character
of Kevin Crum is based on Billy Milligan
and uses a lot of the same terminology
that's they're probably gonna make it
kind of like that Dexter series I wonder
something like that
which I love that series that was good I
wouldn't mind seeing that again I still
have to start that up again aren't they
they did start that up again like they
had a new season but I haven't seen it
yeah maybe it's no good I don't know
well I don't know I heard it was okay
but I haven't I haven't really seen the
platforms at all
um I can't remember
do you think it'd be on Netflix yeah you
would think that but I don't think it is
though but I'd have to check I don't
remember where they put it
but um but yeah so so I don't know
what's gonna happen with that Tom
Holland thing but I think it's going to
be on it's like 10 episodes or something
like that so it's like a mini series
and uh so I don't know what's I was
gonna say one more thing and then I
forgot what it was
when you were saying about Dexter it
reminded me of something
and now I can't remember what yeah you
[__] it up you always like well you
always like say something and then I
just like lost my train of thought
you know what I mean but yeah so if you
have Netflix uh this documentary is
actually pretty interesting
um but oh I remember what I was gonna
say okay see one thing that well it
didn't have anything to do with Dexter
though one thing and a couple of the
people on the documentary like brought
this up as well and I kind of feel like
you know maybe we're feeding into this
whole thing but because Billy Milligan
and his multiple personality thing
whether it was real or not became such a
media sensation
um I feel like people kind of like
forgot about the victims yeah you know
what I mean
um because I'm sitting there saying
they're just like letting him run around
living the Hollywood lifestyle I mean
they didn't let him run around he
escaped to be fair but even when he was
in the hospital at first they gave him
like all these Privileges and they just
like let him run I'm like he's a rapist
though and the thing about it was that
he was really he seemed really good at
manipulating people like to get what he
wanted and he was able to convince a
large number of people
whether it was true or not that he
genuinely was not a threat because he
genuinely did not
he wasn't aware
um of his other personalities getting up
to these Shenanigans while he was asleep
or whatever like while he wasn't on the
spot
now
I don't know how I feel about that
because like even if
even if it was true that he had all
these other Personalities in there
they're out there like committing crimes
and he wasn't aware of it I'm like yeah
but you don't know I mean it doesn't
seem fair to punish somebody that didn't
know anybody anything about it but then
on the other hand it's like you never
know when he's gonna like pop into a
different personality and go around
doing [__] like yeah you gotta
incarcerate somebody like that's what I
mean so it's just kind of like and I
mean really I mean it seems like
they probably did the best thing they
could have done like putting them in a
mental health facility because clearly
he had mental health issues it's not you
know what I mean so I don't think that
was I think he would have done better
there than prison
but I don't think they should have
necessarily just let him run around
loose like that yeah because he didn't
he didn't reoffend rapes again but he
killed people after that allegedly
allegedly seems seems to have killed
some people I mean I would be very
surprised if he didn't at least kill
that Michael Madden guy
because he was one the last person that
he was seen with and he was arguing and
he cashed checks and sold his car after
he was dead goes back to what I was
saying
on other shows
a serial killer is nothing more than
just a serial rapist that kills the
victim
if you do three of them you're a [__]
serial rapist and and basically the same
kind of person as a serial killer you
might you're going to evolve into that
if you let that person just do what he
wants for a long right especially if you
send him to prison then he comes back
out he's gonna start killing people
which is kind of what he did yeah
um so even though he seems like he
killed the people for a different reason
seems like a very different reason but
there's no telling what happened maybe
he can female victims in different ways
to to cover his tracks
maybe it looked like something else you
know
he may have killed some women too
that's what I'm saying because they kind
of after he got you know like released
from State custody in 1991 they kind of
lost track of him for maybe like a
decade like even his family and stuff
didn't know where he was so it's like
and the fact that those two dudes that
he allegedly killed they never found
their bodies they still haven't yeah so
so the women would have been disposed of
so he might have killed other people
yeah and they just don't know about it
yet yeah it's a serial rapist and a
serial killer is the same
it's the same thing
you catch a serial rapist he should
never be released crazy or not
that's his sexual orientation I mean
either put him in prison or put him in a
hospital forever right yeah he should
never be released I mean I'm not arguing
with their decision to put him in a
mental health facility
that's probably where he should be but I
don't think they should have let him out
I don't think they should have let him
even if he even if he's okay which I
kind of doubt it even if he was you know
you should still be in there for life
it's just a risk
your risk yeah yeah
Ben says uh I brought this up like a
long time ago maybe you weren't here how
did he actually get caught for the rapes
did someone recognize him fingerprints
or DNA um two of those things uh the
victims recognized him from a mug shot
because he had been arrested before uh
for sexual assault and for robbery like
when he was minor and uh his
fingerprints were in the car and also
when they searched his house
um they found some of the girls stuff
like they found their credit cards and
like jewelry and stuff like that that he
had taken from them so they knew it was
him he just claimed that he didn't
remember what was going on and why he
was arrested and stuff like that but
yeah all the women identified him very
easily picked him out of a lineup in his
fingerprints serial killers usually
start off as peeping Toms and people
that invade homes
and then rape people they become serial
rapists then they usually do some time
for that and then when they get out they
decide they're not going to let the
victim live they didn't come serial
killers that's the very basic pattern
they don't all fit that each one's an
individual
but it's it's always a pattern of
escalation it's a and it's it's
definitely
sexual it's a sexual
orientation
it's rape basically that's what it is
yeah this guy was unusual like I said in
the sense that
um you know the rapes he didn't kill the
women
I mean he did kidnap them and [__] like
that but he just like it apparently he
didn't cover up his face or nothing like
that because they recognized him
but then later on when he allegedly
killed people
um they think that he killed the two
guys that he killed for different
reasons like that was more like a
robbery kind of thing and when he raped
the women he robbed them as well
like as it seemed like mostly he was a
robbery guy
was the main thing
you know yeah and the three rapes that
he did now he did another one too when
he was a minor like when he was 17.
that's why they had him on file you know
yeah
all right so we've been going for
two hours that was a good show at eight
minutes it's a good show yeah I thought
it was gonna be and like I said I
actually had time to do like a lot of
research on this one I thought I found
it really interesting you know what I
mean yeah uh Michael said you guys are
easy to shop for black goth shirts yeah
pretty much we make these that I make
these yeah yeah we made most yeah we
made both of these like I just I
designed this one yeah she designed to
my execute yeah that's just something I
made for we made for a client too yeah
that was for that's for a goth music
YouTube channel called obscura Undead
yeah yeah our friend our friend um
uh Sherry is on there a lot Sherry Mouse
yeah she's one of the original members
that's very good one of the few black
goth girls in the scene she's a DJ from
up in uh
uh Tampa cute as a bug married this dude
do we know
yeah she DJs a lot of the shows over
there in Tampa yeah actually you can
look her up Sherry Mouse
on Facebook you'll see who it is yeah
yeah she's super nice too yeah all right
so I guess we're gonna wrap it up so I
can
go to bed yeah because I gotta get up
real early tomorrow we've been up since
five I'm actually we're we did good I
think we're still we're still awake yep
and it's kind of perky but uh yeah
hopefully you guys can join us again on
Friday night for the side track show
um I think Memento Mori is Friday this
Friday can you do something yeah but
we'll see but yeah so we'll be back on
Friday night for the Sidetrack show
thank you for dropping by and hanging
out with us this evening hopefully you
found the show interesting please like
and share and comment and all that good
stuff for the algorithm and we will see
you guys again on Friday night good
night